l'accident mortel est impliquée ici sur
l'a6 à hauteur de saint cyr des colons
80 un peu avant 5 heures du matin une
camionnette a été percuté violemment par
l'arrière par un poids lourd
le conducteur de la camionnette un homme
est mort sur le coup
le carambolage a mis en cause deux
autres poids lourds et a causé aussi un
blessé grave et deux blessés légers les
trois hommes ont été transportés à
l'hôpital d'auxerre cet accident mortel
s'avère en fait un sur accident
un premier accident matériel s'était
produit quelques instants plus tôt près
de deux kilomètres plus loin dans le
même sens de circulation lyon paris ce
poids lourd est alors couché en
portefeuille
les voitures ont dû ralentir un bouchon
s'est formé et c'est là que l'accident
mortel s'est produit
l'autoroute est restée fermée plusieurs
heures en milieu de matinée la
circulation a pu reprendre ici sur l'a6
dans le sens lyon paris mais sur une
seule voie comme vous le voyez peut-être
derrière moi le trafic devait revenir à
la normale en fin de matinée après ce
double accident mortel qui a fait je
vous le rappelle une victime